I want to start with a dramatic  confession  because I know that you were complaining  in a recent interview that you always  have to talk about Star Wars in  interviews I can probably make that  easier for you because I I have never  watched any of the Star Wars movies  well that's  Viva La difference you know  I'm glad I'm glad people don't I I'll  like the same things it'd be very boring  I've got to say that notwithstanding  that my eldest son discovered that you  were on tonight I don't think I've ever  known him more excited he's nearly 30.  he has one of those things that you wave  around I know in the movies the the  lightsaber Lifesavers  um and he is so incredibly excited about  this so I might at the end just ask you  to send him the force or or whatever it  is but you'll be pleased to know I'm  gonna